cual valor de x hace que el paro
ordenado x menos 7 sea una solución para
la siguiente desigualdad y esta es la
desigualdad que nos dicen 2 x menos 7 y
menor que 25 nos da estas opciones y los
invitó a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de encontrar la solución por su cuenta
vamos a resolverlo juntos nos están
restringiendo que lleva a ser igual a
menos 7 esta es una condición que nos
dan por lo que podemos sustituir esta
menos 7 en la ye y nos queda 2x menos 7
porque pero hoy es menos 7 x menos 7 y
todo esto es menor que 25
y esto es 2 x menos 7 x menos 7 va a ser
igual a más 49
esto es 2 x + 49 y todo esto es menor
que 25 ahora queremos despejar la x para
dejarla sola vamos a comenzar quitando
este 49 para quitar el 49 tengo que
restar 49 en ambos lados de la
desigualdad lo hacemos esto menos 49 y
de este lado también menos 49 hacemos la
operación esto se va y nos queda de este
lado 2 x menor que 25 menos 49
49 25 serían 24 pero como aquí tenemos
el menos sería menos 24 menos 24 y como
queremos dejar sola a la equis vamos a
dividir ambos lados
entre 2 no cambia la desigualdad porque
estamos multiplicando dividiendo con un
número positivo entonces 2x entre 2 se
va esto me queda la x menor que menos 24
entre 2 va a ser igual a menos 2 x es
menor que menos 12 y afortunadamente
aquí tenemos la opción x menor que menos
2 esta es nuestra respuesta siempre que
nuestra ya sea igual a menos 7 y nuestra
x se mantenga por debajo del -12 no
igual a menos 12 porque no es menor o
igual siempre que sea menor que menos 12
se va a cumplir esta desigualdad hagamos
otro problema cuáles valores de iu hacen
que el par ordenado en el problema
anterior lo que nos restringían
era la playa tiene un valor fijo ahora
es la equis la que tiene un valor fijo
nos restringen la equis y nos preguntan
cuál valor de g hace que el paro
ordenado 5 g
sea una solución a la desigualdad
representada en la siguiente gráfica
aquí no nos dan la solución algebraica
sino visual y para estar en la solución
debemos de mantenernos en esta área azul
esta área azul de aquí por ejemplo si
fuera este punto que es menos 56 sería
una solución para esta desigualdad sin
embargo algo que esté exactamente en la
línea no sería solución pues tomen nota
de que ésta es una línea punteada si
fuera una línea completa sin estos
espacios indicaría que lo que está sobre
la línea también se considera parte de
la solución pero como es una línea
punteada lo que está en la línea no
puede ser parte de la solución sólo
aquellas cosas que estén por en sí
de esta línea van a ser solución que es
lo que nos piden bueno nos están
diciendo que x va a ser igual a 5
entonces x igual a 5 es esta línea
pero si nos piden que esté en la
solución el par ordenado tenemos que
estar en esta región azul como podemos
restringir allí para que nos limite a
estar en la solución pues tenemos que
restringir a ye para que se encuentre
por encima de esta línea así que si
nuestra restricción es 5 entonces
nuestros pares ordenados posibles van a
encontrarse aquí por encima de la línea
azul aquí van a estar nuestros puntos
posibles y de hecho estos puntos podrían
continuar hacia arriba si yo quisiera
así que ya va a tener que ser mayor que
y no mayor o igual recuerden que no
podemos incluir los puntos que se
encuentran sobre la línea pues es una
línea punteada tiene que ser algo que
sea mayor de lo que está en la línea y
en este caso este punto está en 7 por lo
que ya tiene que ser mayor que 7 no
mayor o igual mayor que 7 para que
apunte a todo lo que está arriba en esta
línea x
que me debe ser mayor que 7 qué
esta opción de aquí si x es igual a 5
entonces ya tiene que ser mayor que 7
para que este palo ordenado sea solución
de esta desigualdad